[Music]
okay
i think we're now live so welcome
everybody to today's licensing committee
uh to consider the application for a
premises license uh for rocker
the hardware grade landscape my name is
williams clapsman and i
am going to facilitate the uh beginning
of the meeting which is the election of
the chair
so please have a nomination
councillor boundary thank you very much
and you second that yes
thank you lovely okay then without
further ado i'll hand over to that's the
band bridge as jeff thank you very much
thank you and welcome everyone today's
meeting of the licensing
team prior to this meeting all
participants have previously checked
that they can be heard and seen
and can see and hear other members to
double check this and principles
everyone from the present at this remote
meeting
attendance and your role or job title
when i say your name
miss brock yes uh alison brock licensing
officer
councillor scobee
harry cody cliftonville west
what's the era council russian our
councilor for central harbour ramsay
miss phillips jennifer phillips
principal litigation lawyer for fanatic
district council
mr claxton
james hatson democratic services officer
clark in the meeting
miss berry madbury environmental health
officer
mr white
oh sorry michelle greg police licensing
officer for thanet
okay uh mr greensbury
hello andy grimsey solicitor for the
applicant
thank you mr brewer
hello democratic services officer
streaming um
yeah unfortunately he can't join this
meeting but he's watching
okay thank you i'm heidi colin
good morning sergeant heidi collins of
the phallic community safety unit
and mr
okay thank you everyone have i missed
anyone present today
no okay if you have any technical
difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
katie the democratic services officer on
call who will attempt to assist you
from zero one eight four three four five
yeah uh alison could you need your
microphone for me
yeah thank you
sorry so if you have any technical
difficulties please contact the
democratic services officer
on call we will attempt to assist you on
zero one eight four three
five double seven o four six she she'll
put
her phone number in the chat function
thank you katie
um i would ask participants when you're
not speaking to please mute your
microphone this minimize background
noise and will help everyone in
listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat to the
right side
of the screen and i will then make a
note and go back to you once the person
speaking has finished
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned
silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
do not turn off your phones in case you
need to be contacted in the event of
technical difficulties
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business and ensure
that you're in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public
except for
the private deliberation part of this
meeting a separate private
hangout meeting will take place for this
element of item 4
and the public meeting will resume in
its previous digital digital location 30
minutes later
unless there is a reason to suggest an
earlier or later time
no one authorized recording of the
confidential item of business is
permitted to take place
are there any apologies for absence
no apologies um are there any
declarations of interest
no declarations
um okay application for premises license
um rocker i call upon miss phillips the
council's principal litigation solicitor
to explain to the parties the procedure
that we will be taking during the
hearing
good morning and thank you i would like
everyone present
to know that the decisions made by this
subcommittee are made in accordance with
the license in act
2003 and based on the information
percent
presented in this agenda together with
any verbal submissions made
today decisions of the subcommittee are
not politically based
this subcommittee will act impartially
and offer a fair and unbiased hearing
of today's application and will give
fair consideration to the evidence heard
and read today
we are here to consider the application
of rook unlimited
of 64 harbor parade ramsgate kent
ct 11 8 ln for a new premises license
in respect of the same address which is
64 harbour parade ramsgate kent ct 118
lm
under section 11 of the licensing act
2003 for the premises described
in the application dated the 22nd of
december 2020. the application being
made
to thanat district council as the
relevant licensing authority
in accordance with section 12 of the
licensing act
the premises does have a license
which permits the sale of alcohol seven
days a week
until three o'clock with a close of 3 30
and the license is in the name of mr
nicholas pantelli
but this application is for a new
license
we will hear the parties in the
following order
the licensing officer and then the
applicant for
the license and any representatives
from the police and then from the
environment
to half off each party has
up to 15 minutes to make its rep its
presentation
and this includes any witness that's
called
you will not be allowed to introduce any
new evidence at this stage
that has not been disclosed in this
proceeding
i will have to interrupt if there is any
attempt to do so
you are not expected not quite to talk
the full
15 minutes for presentation the members
of the subcommittee
may ask questions of each party
or their representative and of any
witnesses there is no time limit for
members questions
and there's no automatic right for the
parties to question one another
except with permission and if
questions are allowed and they would be
limited to
around five minutes at the end of the
proceedings each party will have
five minutes to make a closing statement
in the following order
the applicant for the license any
representatives
the police will sum up and then the
environmental health
officer and please note that to ensure
that
the virtual meeting runs smoothly only
one individual shall be allowed to speak
at a time
and any person speaking must be
permitted to finish
what they are saying about interruption
um the meeting will then adjourn
as has been stated earlier for the
committee to consider its decision
and when we do adjourn the subcommittee
members the legal officer
and the clerk shall leave the virtual
meeting and if you would like to hear
the decision of the subcommittee as was
stated
um we'll advise everyone of the
decision approximately 30 minutes
from the time of the adjournment you can
either remain
in the virtual meeting due this time or
you can use the link again to access the
meeting
if you do decide to wait in the virtual
meeting room
please turn off your cameras and
microphones to ensure your privacy
as the recording will continue and there
concludes my
import for now
thank you mr lopes i would like to
stress the importance of following the
hearing procedure
and that there will be an opportunity
for parties to make a final
presentation after questioning therefore
i would advise all present
please follow the procedure and to
respect those speaking by not
interrupting or speaking over others
if people do interrupt or speak over
others i as chairman will be asking them
to refrain from doing so
if they continue to do yourselves by
warning then that individual could face
being asked to leave the meeting
so um could the licensing officer please
present the report
morning everyone um an application has
been made by rocker limited for a new
premises license at rocker harbour
parade rams day
the applicant currently holds a licence
for this premises and has submitted this
application as a new
one to increase opening hours and hours
of licensable activities
should this application not be approved
the applicant can revert back to the
current license that's already in place
at annex 2 you'll find a chart which
gives you the current licensing hours
and the requested new hours
one representation has been received
from the police which is also attached
to annex 3.
environmental health of not objective
but objected should i
say but have requested that
doesn't be granted the conditions which
have been included within the
application
are attached as part of the license the
application the applicant has submitted
supporting
statements in reply to the objection
from the police and this can also be
found at annex 5.
thank you
oh sorry i was muted um thank you alison
um would the applicant um agent please
present their application thank you
uh chair um yes as i said i'm
andy grimsy's solicitor for the
applicant in a moment i'm going to ask
nick pantelli to
to address you uh you may be well
i'm sure you are aware that there was
some documentation a further
um uh representation if you like um
submitted by the police
yesterday and there's a couple of things
arising from that that we'd like to
address you
on if if that's acceptable um
i i just nick is going to be quite
comprehensive in what he says
and i just want to frame what he says
in this context please the relationship
with the police
is very good nick is a very
long-standing operator
and i hope you can see from the
correspondence from the police that
there is a lot of mutual respect there
this case may your decision may come
down to
the degree of trust that you are
prepared to put in nick as an operator
rather than the temptation to write
everything down
on a license as a as a condition that
may be the question
if that is something that is live with
you i would just point to
the statement that is at page 53 of the
bundle and what nick is about to tell
you
uh as a sort of um further information
uh to show that there can't be a better
person in whom to place your trust
than somebody like nick pantelli uh he
is a long-standing operator if you look
at the detail of that statement you will
see how much diligence
he has put into trying to address any
concerns that there may be
and to base what we are asking for on
on evidence yes we know that we will
have if this is granted
uh the the latest operating hours in
ramsgate
but i would suggest that
particularly in light of the covid
pandemic and the devastating effect it's
had on
all licensed premises nick included if
trust is one of those things that you
are
affecting your decision today nick is
the man that you can trust
to do it and when the police have
mentioned a fear of the flood gates
being opened
uh i have submitted a case
which i trust has been afforded to your
uh solicitor
uh which basically says thank you um
jennifer is nodding
um basically the guidance says that
every case should be treated on its own
merits and therefore
we would ask you to treat nick's case
our case on its own merits
and if anybody else in the future wants
to apply then of course that is up to
them and you will decide based upon
their
merit or otherwise if you don't mind
chair i know we're limited with time i'm
going to ask nick to
address you now uh nikki you're okay
with that
yes sir thanks andy good morning
everyone
um as you would have had from from andy
and from
jennifer we've um we already have a 3
a.m license 7 days a week since 2006
and we have used temporary event notices
each year
for an extra hour trading mainly on bank
holidays
and on other special events throughout
the year
we would estimate that we have run well
over 200 tens notices until 4am at the
premises
so we're very experienced in doing so
with this application
we are seeking an extra hour from
thursday to saturday on our license
which will allow us to operate with a
lot more flexibility
than the temporary events notices
currently allow
i would however like to reassure the
subcommittee and the police
that it is certainly not my intention to
trade every single
thursday friday and saturday night
throughout the year until 4am
and if the license is granted it would
be used sensibly
much in the same manner as our temporary
event notices have been in the past
on bank holiday special events and
during our peak
season there are no conditions on our
existing premises license
other than those previously agreed with
environmental health in 2010
despite this for over 15 years we have
operated responsibly
well in excess of the requirements of
our licence
with measure measures which include cctv
door supervisors body-worn cameras metal
detectors
uv lights spike test kits
and most recently an ib scanner
we have been in discussions with the
police regarding the application
and had agreed 15 conditions which were
proportionate to promote the licensing
objectives
these were included in the application
and we proceeded on that basis
having consulted with each responsible
authority
the original police objection in the
hearing documents
asked for three further conditions which
i would like to touch on
the first is the last entry at 1am and
re-entry at am this is something i feel
very strongly about
we do not have a last entry in our
existing 3am license
nor have we ever been asked to impose
any such restriction
on any of the temporary event notices we
have previously held over the last 15
years
there is no last entry for any other
venue along harbor parade with 3am
or 4am opening hours law premises in
fanet
with 6 am licenses so this will place us
in a totally
disadvantageous position with a huge
financial downside
pre-covered on average 80
of our customers would arrive after 1am
on a thursday and around 50 percent
arrive after 1am on fridays and
saturdays
in terms of revenue this equates to
around 86
on thursdays 80 on fridays
and 66 percent on saturdays hence any
last
entry would be extremely detrimental to
the business
it would prevent people from coming to
us from other premises
not only in ramsgate and other towns in
thanet but also further afield
and with the prospect of vastly
increased staycations looming over us
due to the travel restrictions in place
we should be encouraging and promoting
tourism in all of our towns across danny
now more than ever and finally it is
just not necessary to promote the
licensing objectives
our entry policy is robust and any
refusals are just as likely to take
place at 10 pm
as they are at 2 or 3 am
the second condition suggested was to
bring tables and chairs inside
after 2am again no other venue has such
a condition
and there is little rationale for it we
have been licensed by kent highways for
temporary street furniture
during our opening hours for 15 years
and in my experience
people sat down uncomfortable are far
less likely
to cause antisocial behavior this would
also be totally impractical
in terms of physically being able to
remove tables and chairs at 2am
and would cause issues with where to
store them when the premises were open
and still trading
not to mention the condition is against
government covered guidance
which encourages venues to maximize the
use of outdoor space where possible
the last condition suggested by the
police
were those proposed by environmental
health which were already included in
the application
following the additional submission by
the police yesterday
i'm pleased that the police are
satisfied that these have now been
suitably addressed
and that they are no longer seeking
these particularly onerous conditions
the police also provided an incident log
from august
2019 to february 2020
which i have commented on in detail um
however to summarize there are 17
incidents in total nine of which did not
occur
at the venue three are highly
questionable
and there are only five confirmed at the
venue
of those five three were allegations
made towards doorstop none of which were
followed up and none of which supported
a prosecution
this leaves just two actual incidents
which is of course two more than we
would like
critically there have been no incidents
at the venue past
3 am and on any temporary events notices
we have held over the years
there has been no objection from
environmental health
however i would like to address the
comments
in the hearing pack so there are no
clouds left hanging over us
it points to two complaints received
the first of which was on september the
14th
uh which i wrote to miss berry asking
for more detail on
to uh investigate and take any remedial
action if it was required
but i heard nothing back um i was
skeptical of this
complaint as in september we were
operating
under strict tiered covered regulations
which included everyone had to be seated
and the music level could only be played
at a background
level and i was working on the night in
question
so i said that one you know i
i don't know where to go with it um ea
also mentioned another complaint on the
22nd of january 2020
which was not brought to our attention
until i received the hearing pack
um however you know once i've looked
into this
um it's clear that this was a wednesday
night
in january and given the fact that we
only opened thursday to saturday out of
season
we were quite simply not open so again
this is either frivolous or perhaps
a tribute attributable to other venues
which may have been open
there have been some discussions behind
the scenes with police
which have been conducted in good faith
by both parties to try and reach an
agreement prior to the hearing
and the main sticking point is in
relation to door staff
we have never had a licensed condition
requiring us to even have door staff
at the venue but we have always used
door supervisors for the last 15 years
and it is of course a sensible measure
to have in place
we have previously agreed with the
police that during our peak season
from easter bank holiday to the august
bank holiday inclusive
on fridays and saturdays that there
should be a minimum
of one sia from 10 p.m and a further one
sia from 11 p.m until the premises
closes
at all other times the need for door
staff shall be risk assessed and
cognizance will be taken of police
advice
a site visit by the subcommittee under
normal circumstances would have been
useful to see the size
and shape of the premises there was a
plan
submitted which may assist
but we are not a large premises by any
means we're approximately 80 meters long
by 6 meters wide
and the shape of the venue is a big
rectangle
that means that there are very good
lines of sight
from one end of the venue to the other
including the outdoor areas
there is also a cctv monitor at the
front door
which enables door staff to check other
areas at all times
and all our staff are on radio two-way
radios
so we can communicate with each other
throughout the premises
we have a risk assessment in place for
door staff
and we follow this every weekend when we
are planning the number of door staff
and the start times to ensure the
premises is run responsibly
and safely whilst promoting the
licensing objectives
these decisions are taken by management
and are head doormen
and input is always welcome from the
police
we take many factors into account such
as how busy the night is expected to be
identifying peak periods any special
risks associated
with a particular night or weekend
consideration is given to the time of
year current trends
weather conditions and any specific
nature of the events being held at the
premises
or externally that may impact on
footfall or customer arrival times
so that we can minimize any risk
additional security measures are put in
place
for historically busy events such as
halloween
the run-up to christmas throughout
december and new year's eve for example
at the door staff on ramsgate seafront
all work for the same security
contractor
mark one security they are all in
communication with each other
with uh radios throughout the night and
share information to prevent
crime and disorder they can and often do
support each other at other venues
should the need arise in 2019 the last
full year of trading our door staff
assisted other venues and the police on
72 occasions throughout the year
on only one occasion where other door
staff called to our premises
and that was purely for monitoring to
ensure an incident was properly recorded
on body-worn camera
in short outdoor team is very
experienced and can look after our venue
and we have always provided much more
support
and assistance to other door staff and
other venues than we have ever received
i can assure you that a friday night in
january
or february is very different from a
friday night in july or august
right nicolas but i'm just letting you
know that you're coming towards the end
of your time now
yeah i'll close up i'll close up uh
we're a very seasonal business
we need to be able to adjust our staff
levels accordingly
as we do with our bartenders and our
glass collectors
and to keep our operating costs in line
with our revenue
throughout the year and just to give you
an idea
in 2019 we spent over thirty six
thousand five hundred pound on security
at the premises
uh what the police are asking for would
push his figure to over fifty thousand
pound
which is a huge increase in expenditure
at any time let alone in the current
climate
and in my opinion it's not necessary
when we have demonstrated for many years
that we are very proactive on this front
our proposed condition for door staff
is fair and appropriate for the size of
venue
and hopefully the fact that we have used
door staff regularly for 15 years
and never been caught short will assure
you that i would never leave my venue
under staff
in any capacity let alone withdrawal
staff
okay thank you and does the licensing
team have any question
questions for the applicant um yeah well
one
question one's comment really um just
you don't actually have a current
pavement license
so you will need to apply for one before
you open
and also could you explain to
the committee why you've put this in as
a
new premises application and not as a
variation which is often what most
people do
thank you um i i will answer that
uh if that's okay chair uh the the
latter question
um being a licensing solicitor of 17
years experience
uh we have sometimes come across um
uh applications when we've issued
variations
of licenses and things have cropped up
where
um it hasn't turned out how we hoped the
application has turned out and we've
come away with something which was worse
than
what our client wanted in the first
place because of the nature of
conditions that could be put on licenses
we regularly advise our clients across
the country
if they are applying for something that
may be contentious
it might be easier and clearer to
apply for a new license so that
everybody knows the councillors the
authorities everybody knows this will be
the new license uh if it's granted on
terms which
uh our client is uh is happy with we
will then adopt that license and
surrender the old one
if it if it goes badly wrong and we get
a license we don't like
we just you tear it up quite frankly so
it is a commercial
risk-based strategy there's nothing
there's no um
chicanery uh behind the scenes about it
it's uh
it's a regular practice for for
specialist licensing solicitors in my
experience anyway
it certainly doesn't reflect on on nick
in any way at all i don't know whether
allison can confirm that but
that's the position um alice can i
just touch on the pavement license yet
we normally apply to ken
highways we applied last year our check
and
application was returned we're aware
that fanuc council
are now responsible for pavement
licenses and before we reopen
we will of course submit the paperwork
that you need and the fee
to process that application for us
lovely thank you that's great thank you
alison
um did the police have any questions for
the applicant
yes i do um i just have two questions um
one being what is the rationale and
reason
for not employing extra door staff to
cover these extra hours
as recommended by the sia authority
that's the first question my second
question is what control measures will
be introduced if mr pantelli
doesn't agree to the police condition
requiring two
sir sia door staff from 2300 hours
an additional one from oh 100 hours for
example if an incident incurs
inside the premises requiring two door
staff
that would mean that the front entrance
of rocker
will be unattended and no security
measures there
so there are my two questions for mr
pantali
sorry there's some feedback yeah
that's not me sorry um i i i'm not
i'm not quite comfortable with this um
reference by
from michelle to the sia
guidance i i i don't i don't quite know
what
um the police are saying is the guidance
and i don't know what the provenance is
i certainly know and having spoken with
several colleagues who are as
experienced as me
in licensing matters that there isn't
any specific
guidance you know it's very much like
applications one has to uh
um address particular risk situations
uh with with the appropriate amount of
door staff uh
it's not based necessarily on capacity
or on time or
size or or whatever it's a it's a
holistic
approach so um before nick answers i i
think it might help everybody if
michelle could perhaps clarify what she
is saying the guidance is
uh and perhaps the justification for if
you don't mind michelle sorry
yeah no problem um after speaking to
some sia door staff
and managers they are saying that the
ratio
is one door staff to 75 patrons that is
what they are looking at
when they have premises licensed
premises so
with regards to mr pantelli maybe having
a 200 capacity
we've looked at one door staff to 75
patrons which would be two dollar staff
to 150
rocker is 200 so we are asking for that
third
door staff to cover the patrons inside
the premises
yes it's guidance only but for the
protection of the people inside the
premises
and the door staff that is what we're
asking
yeah um speaker
just to reiterate what andy said the sia
is a regulatory body
and does not specify i recommend the
number of door staff at venues
nor that start finishing times we've
operated the venue
for 15 years we generally find that one
doorman inside
and one doorman outside is adequate to
manage the venue
there are multiple venues around us
which we can call on for assistance
should we need assistance
which is very rare and in terms of
control measures if door staff are tied
up
a member of management or a member of
our staff will monitor the front door
and we'll simply hold the front door not
allow anyone to enter
until incidents are dealt with and
everyone is safe and sound
well thank you um
nick you you mentioned um getting other
door staff to assist
and that's not really good practice for
door staff to assist other premises but
at three o'clock in the morning when all
the other premises in landscape will be
shut
you will only have your two-door staff
on that harbour front
so you can't ask for assistance from
other door staff
at three o'clock in the morning when
your promises will be open until half
past four
hence why we're asking for that extra
security
for not only your door staff but the
patrons inside
um for their safety thank you
yeah if you know we risk assess our
events
and if it falls on a bank holiday or a
special event or expect to be busy
we will of course bolster up our
security as we have done
on any every occasion for the last 15
years and during any temporary events
that we have run as well
so we we know how to handle our premises
you know if it gets to the point
where we're busy we'll just simply stop
letting people in
uh we were the only premises trading
from 11 o'clock
um over the summer uh in the whole of
thanet
and we had no issue with our two doormen
you know dealing with the premises
supported by our management and other
members of staff
thank you um does the environmental
health officer have any questions the
applicant
good morning uh yes just just two thanks
to nick for clarifying
uh the issues around the complaints
we've received um
we did write to you um it appears you
didn't receive the second
notification but also i didn't receive
your response so
um but thank you for clarifying that uh
the questions i have one
is in relation to temporary events
notice it
notices that as you say you've applied
for over 200
probably over the last few years and to
obtain that extra hour of trading to
take you to
um four o'clock for regulated
entertainment 430 closure which is what
you're seeking
to achieve with this this new
application and i suppose i want to know
is
if if this license is granted are you
going to submit further applications and
extend the hours to
5 and 5 30 respectively so if you could
clarify that
and then the second point would be um in
relation to noise control measures at
the venue
obviously since 2010 which is when we
last had
issues around noise and ultimately a
review and conditions imposed
i just wanted to know because we set the
limiter at that time
whether you have undertaken any
additional noise control measures so for
example
secondary acoustic glazing a lobby door
um sound proofing to walls that kind of
thing or if it's
in the same sort of situation as it was
back when we set the limiter in 2010.
thank you yeah i'll address both of
those amanda
um no we're not going to be seeking any
later hours
than four o'clock um it's not my
intention to trade past four o'clock
you know on any event um throughout the
year
we haven't done in the past and i don't
intend to in the future
and regard to noise control measures and
we have a limiter in place
it's regularly checked by our sound
engineer to ensure it's working at the
right levels
um the front windows have been double
glazed
um which may be a additional improvement
we haven't done a
you know an updated sound test on it but
it could only be an improvement
um to what we've had previously but we
haven't had we have not had a complaint
since 2010 so
i would submit that you know what we
have in place works
is working and will continue to work
thank you
thank you um do members of the committee
have any questions for the applicant
that's the scoby um counsellor error um
if you're not on
your microphone council error
council lara do you have a question yes
thank you yeah
yeah to mr pantali uh are you thinking
of uh offering some
special offers throughout the week or
any evenings uh
like you know ramsgate is known for
thursday thursdays or you know cheap
drinks
so are you planning to do something like
this during the
week like that's not our intention and
that's not our market
um you know we do not want to go down
that route i mean our standard price for
a drink is about four pound 80
and you can get a pint of beer in
weather spoons for 125
so we are complete opposite ends of the
spectrum
thank you i've got a question
um i noted that you said on the last
century
um it had been um the condition had been
put in place um
but also also the chairs being removed
from the four core at um 2pm
is that in your previous um license
um no neither of those are in our
previous license
um they were what were they were points
raised by the police on their original
uh representation um but neither of
those
are on our current license or on any
temporary event notice that we have
operated in the past okay
all right thank you and um
i'm sorry i didn't i'm sorry again to um
nicholas pantalia
um could you just sorry clarify and the
question that we had regarding
um your i take it the night the
neighboring
um um pubs restaurants close at three
o'clock is that right 3 30.
yes some of them have three o'clock some
of them have four o'clock licenses as
well
okay so so um how is it that you went
anticipating to cover that when you
when you said about the um um getting um
other other
doormen to help if there was you know an
incident
um that option that you know is
available to us
um we generally find that you know our
two doormen who are very experienced
you know over 10 years experience um in
sia and in our head dorman has a
military background
um that you know we have not had issues
operating until four o'clock in the
morning now on
on many of the occasions when we will
will propose to be operating until four
in the morning
many of our neighbors other bars also
put in temporary events
you know um miss barry can confirm that
the police can confirm that
so on many of these occasions on the
bank holidays on your easters
you know throughout the summer new
year's eve there will be other places
open until four o'clock
so i think that the police's concern on
that is a little bit exaggerated
okay all right thank you um well is um
the police
if the police would like to present
their case
good morning um
we have been negotiating with mr pantene
since january 2020
now as we were looking to take rocker to
review due to the amount of
incidents involving his premises these
were discussed with him and a number of
conditions were agreed by both parties
and these are listed in the supplemental
amended
police representations that were sent to
the committee yesterday afternoon
the police have been waiting for a minor
variation in order to add these
conditions to the current premise
license
on the 23rd of december 2020 we received
an application
for a new premise license not a minor
variation
within it were the listed conditions as
previously agreed however
this included an extension to trading
hours
which were not previously discussed
during the first negotiations
new trading hours applied for are the
thursday friday saturday
closing times are over 30 hours
within that there was a request to trade
until o 400 with certain
celebratory days ie valentine's
halloween
and all bank holidays and sunday
preceding bank holidays
also mr pantelli has requested for his
premises to stay open all night
on new year's eve into new year's day
basically trading all night
due to the increased hours and new
year's eve the police
and the lack of door staff we have no
choice but to object to this application
to give us more time to negotiate with
mr panteney and come to an agreement
that works both for us and mr pantelli
and the promotion of the licensing
objective
prevention of the chronic disorder and
public safety
unfortunately we were still negotiating
up until the 11th hour
and we have been able to reach an
acceptable agreement on the main
condition
relating to door staff all of the
following conditions that the
police objected to were conceded and we
agreed
apart from the door staff um condition
and that is that we are asking for two
sia door staff um to be working at
rocker from 2300 hours with an
additional member of door staff from oh
100 hours
we believe this is the least amount of
door staff to manage a capacity of 200
patrons
with regards to the sia guidance
we believe that the hours between 2300
and 04
30 are key and in the application as it
stands there aren't enough suitable
measures taken to uphold the licensing
objectives
currently there are a significant number
of venues that accommodate persons
enjoying the night time economy in
landscape into the early hours and it is
entirely likely that many of these
persons will decide to take advantage of
the venue
offering a significantly later opening
than the other venues
it is also entirely likely that the
influx of patrons from other licensed
premises
in ramsgate will attend rocker to take
advantage of the o430 closing time
at this this influx of patrons will not
just happen from o 300 hours instead
many will want to attend several hours
before
to make the most of to make the most of
the evening
as such there needs to be reasonable
safety measures taken by an applicant
to help keep both the patrons inside the
premises
and those potential patrons outside who
want to gain entry
staff and other members of the public
safe the police are not there to
supplement the lack of door staff but
will attend when matters
rise to prevent crime disorder but
having three door staff on will
definitely provide an active deterrent
to potential troublemakers
and prevent incidents in the first place
we should the premise licence be granted
kemp police ask that the above points
conditions be considered by the
committee as suitable amendments
we only concede on the other points if
mr pantani agrees the door staff
condition
um but we have no if he doesn't we have
no um
choice but to object to this to this
license
um with regards to the door staff
um door stuff from what i understand
um work on their own premises
tell me if i'm incorrect if anyone knows
better than better than me because i'm
not
sure but i'm pretty sure that door staff
are insured
to work on certain premises whilst
they're there so if they move
off a premise to assist another premise
surely then they become in uninsured and
that shouldn't be happening
so when door staff are employed they
should only be working for that
licensed premises not to assist other
door staff if they are in trouble and
so they would become uninsured and in
fact probably breaching
their conditions if a premise license
has the condition for those dollar staff
to be there
um and i think that's about it sorry i'm
just going to ask my colleagues
um also to mention licensing objectives
have to be prioritized
over trust in an individual to ensure
the safety of the public and prevent
crime disorder
thank you
sorry mute again does the applicant um
or agent have any questions
um for the police
um i i just got one chair
michelle forgive me if i misunderstood
what you said but perhaps you clarify
am i writing in you saying that
in the meetings before christmas no
mention was made of
the four o'clock license because i
distinctly remember raising it at the
end of our meeting
with you and heidi and i didn't want the
committee to think that
we had not mentioned it at all because i
yes it was mentioned um prior to your
application
um but i'm talking about when the
negotiations started in january 2020
there was no mention of the 0 400 hour
closing
and trade and oh for 30 hours closing
thank you i could can i ask a question
yes i've got it obviously andy's touched
on it but i've got it in my meeting
notes
on the on the 25th of november that we
discussed um
four o'clock opening hours um my
question
uh to you uh pc greg
is that you know you're aware of our
capacity does our capacity change after
three o'clock in the morning
it's exactly the same
um no your capacity doesn't change but
what does change
um mr telly is that you won't have
the assistance from other door staff if
there are any incidents occur inside
your premises or outside the front
that's what you won't have um because
that's what you've already stated to us
that you rely sometimes on other door
staff to assist you
the point i raised in my statement was
in in 2019
we assisted other venues and other door
doorstop
on 72 occasions and the police
so are you now saying that our door
staff should not assist
other venues or the police in situations
outside the premises
because that's a very dangerous line for
us to you know to be on
if you're saying we should stand off and
not get involved with things where the
door staff can step
in and prevent people getting hurt and
injured then you know
that's a very very risky position to
park
no that's not what i'm saying obviously
your door staff are there to protect
your patrons outside your premises and
inside
purely your premises so the door staff
next door
to the other license they all have to
look after their businesses
that's what i'm saying you can't rely on
other door staff
to assist rocker if the incident occurs
and there's no way the police would
suggest to not to uh have public safety
at the forefront thank you
i think as i stated it's us that provide
the assistance
to other venues not the other way around
my final question for you
is that on the 17 incidents that you
mentioned
in your statement on only two of them
were cctv or body cam footage requested
by the police
so we have body cam footage on both our
doormen
we have cctv available at the premises
why
on 15 of those 17 occasions did the
police not fully investigate
those incidents because in my opinion if
they had it done
many of them would not have made it to
your list
thank you uh mr canteri unfortunately um
that's not up for discussion
and we're discussing your conditions um
and the objection
so um it's that's not up for discussion
okay
thank you okay
does does environmental health um have
any questions for the police
no questions no questions
do members of the committee have any
questions for the police
era yes um
i know that mr pantalis said that no
incident has been taken
inside raqqa but once
they close or other premises closes
in harbor parade all the incident
actually takes place
in harbor street are you aware of this
and
do you actually when you close the
premises
your customers do you actually i know
you are not allowed to sort of
you know tell them where to go but do
you ever
um in your mind do you do you think what
they are
going to be up to you know after after
they come out of your promises and you
are closed
and often i heard that after closing
hours after
i either you know after three o'clock or
four four o'clock
in the in the morning you will still
have people inside the premises i have
heard this
from in a local community and the
residents who live uh
close to the harbour parade so how are
you going to tackle all this problem i
mean there is always a problem in
harvard street
where we have uh taxi stand uh
next to in the middle of their street so
all the customers who any closing
are coming towards the taxes and either
they're going towards the station
or coming for a taxi or they're
congregating in harvested and making
you know huge problem for the for the
residents i think police are aware of
this
it's always been happening for last few
years
so how how are we going to tackle this
problem
thank you
hi councillor question should be
directed at the police
council i think it's it goes to both uh
both the police as well as mr pantele
because
i don't think we have enough uh to
tackle the problem that
that's causing you know the uh problems
in her in in ramsgate itself
it's been a huge huge problem for rams
gate for last few years
i live in the center of uh in the town
and i am aware of
everything thank you
sorry please gonna answer this question
our apologies
um yes councillor we are aware of the
ongoing issues um in ramsgate
and we are happy to to discuss this um
after this hearing
thank you council scoby do you have a
question
for the police okay
um i've i've got a question um
i'm just looking at your s-i-a guidance
and you're saying it's one one door
staff per 75 patrons is that right
yes that's correct and does that and
does that add up to
the number of patrons um that will be in
rocker
um from my understanding correct me mr
pantel if i'm wrong but
um rocker has a capacity of 200. so
the two-door staff would go up to 150
so obviously we need that extra door
staff to
for the extra patrons the extra 50
patrons
[Music]
we've tried to negotiate but we're
asking that extra door staff
from oh 100 hours as i believe the
capacity
at rocker um gets isn't as great
so from what i understand to come one
o'clock a lot of his new business comes
then
um into three o'clock in the morning so
we're asking for that extra security
for those few hours if the license gets
granted till four
half four then we're only asking for one
one more
sia okay
um i think i heard someone say that this
is it this is going to be the latest
license is it in
along that area of ramsgate or is there
somewhere else that has a license later
yes um rocker will be the only
uh premise open until 4 30 in the
morning
the one other premise does have a
license till four
um but it they got granted that before
the licensing act
came out in 2000 2003 and they have
never ever used it
so these are our concerns that rocker
will be the only
premise open until 4 30 in the morning
in ramsgate okay
um
could the environmental health officer
please present their case
thank you environmental health
uh has not objected to this application
subject to conditions being attached
which were on the previous license or
the current license
and have been in included in this
schedule
um on the application but that's not
because we are
not concerned about public nuisance from
patrons
and and and music but just for a bit of
background to explain the conditions
that were on the previous license and
that we have agreed to
have on this license if members are
minded to grant consent it's um
it's the environmental health did take a
review
back in 2010 because of noise complaints
and they were received and investigated
the conditions were then attached and
those conditions the
the key one here really is the sound
limiter condition
um but it is things have changed since
2010 and it's
worth reminding i think committee
members that
the live music act has changed things
significantly so that has effectively
deregulated
live music and recorded music before 11
pm
so as long as the establishment has a
premises license
to sell alcohol has a capacity of less
than 500 people
they can play recorded and live music
every day from 8 a.m to 11 p.m and any
conditions on the license
do not apply unless they've been
attached
subsequent to a review and i think it's
called a suspension 74
but you can correct me if i'm wrong
so the conditions that we've agreed that
uh with the applicant require that from
11 pm
um all music must be um
secured via a sound limiting device
which has been set by environmental well
the levels are advised by environmental
health
um uh and just to explain a bit i
suppose about the two complaints we took
back at the beginning of uh well one was
on the 21st
of january uh 2020
and the second was in september uh 14th
2020 just to explain that
uh initially complainants are given a
mechanism to
take their complaints forward and the
complainants didn't do that so without
that evidence
we cannot corroborate where their
complaint um
we notify the the premises of the
complaints but
we weren't able to get the evidence to
confirm or or not whether the uh
condition was being breached regarding
the sound limiter
or even get the evidence to justify a
subsequent review
so that's just to explain why those
conditions were not taken for
those complaints were not taken forward
um
but partly the reason for not objecting
is the imposition and of the sound
limiting
condition but also um
that with the numerous tens that have
been applied for
because we didn't object to those tens
in fact that was by agreement
early on to see whether mr pantelli
could um
operate the tens we could take each one
on a case-by-case uh basis and if we got
complaints we could object
which we never we never received those
complaints relating to the tens
but it is just worth worth mentioning
that because we didn't object
that 10 was not subject those tens were
not subject to a statement of conditions
so their premises license and the
conditions that were attached to it
were not legally enforceable for the
extra hour
that was being um applied for under the
10
whereas under the new license should it
be granted those conditions will apply
so actually is an additional
safeguarding measure
i am satisfied by mr pantelli saying
that
uh he will not apply for further
attention should this license be granted
um with regard to the the conditions um
i just while we're in this uh format we
have agreed them but it is worth again
just just um mentioning that condition
five which is in the applicant's
um application in
the operating schedule also in annex 3
condition 5 of the existing license
condition 5 states that doors and
windows should be kept closed in any
event except for access and egress after
2am until close
can i suggest we do not include that
condition because it actually
contradicts
the condition above condition two which
requires windows and doors to be kept
closed during regulated entertainment so
that's from 11 pm
so condition 5 is confusing and not
required and the second
condition which is relates to the sound
limiter
it's more or less the same but it's just
been tidied up in accordance with the
institute of licensing guidance on
premises license conditions
to read a noise limiting device must be
installed
and must operate at all times regulated
entertainment takes place at the
premises
the device must be of a type in a
location
and set at a level impr approved in
writing by the council's environmental
health officer
it's very similar but it's more precise
and more enforceable
um so
i just wanted to mention that now so
those those conditions
will apply to regulated entertainment
from 11 p.m
until uh regulate regulated
entertainment finishes
at four um that's it thank you
you um does the applicant agent
um have any questions for the
environmental health officer
just to clarify uh amanda
you you're you are basically sir you are
proposing to amend
slightly the conditions in our
application
to bring them up to date to include the
phrases regulated
payments um which which i can see i can
see
i can see why he would do that um i'm
just looking at nick because obviously
this is the first time we've heard
that looks alright to me um just brings
it up to date
uh so yes that's that's basically what
you're asking is that right
yes please and the removal of condition
five which is doors and windows should
be kept closed
um after two a.m it's not it's it's it
contradicts the condition above
which is condition two which requires it
closed during regulated entertainment
from 11.
okay thank you thank you thanks thank
you
okay thank you and did the police have
any questions the environmental health
officer
no i don't thank you okay thank you um
do members of the committee um have any
questions
the environmental health officer count
councillor aaron thank you yes just one
question so i'm little bit confused so
after
2 a.m shouldn't be any customer outside
is everybody going to be inside or what
and all the tables and chairs it stays
as it is
would you clarify that please thank you
i i think that's possibly one for
clarification
from um the agent and the applicant and
what they were
asking for but as i understand it their
patrons will be able to sit outside
until the
premises close closes at 4 30 um
but please correct me if i'm if i've got
that wrong
so if that's the case then what happens
to the noise fully
noise you know if people are sitting
outside the premises
and they're going to be drinking and
talking and people will be coming in and
out of the premises as well so the how
are we going to control the noise
that would be for uh mr pantelli to
control that if anybody's um
causing a disturbance i mean bearing in
mind there is quite a bit of hubbub
um in that when other bars are open
prior to that
but mr it would fall to mr pantelli um
and his management to um resolve that
um yes you do need to consider as a
committee whether
the extra hour that's been applied for
is going to impact further
on the surrounding um properties
including and that needs to take into
account the neighboring
businesses which is a hotel and there
are flats above
i believe all of the properties along
there so that does need to be born in
mind
thank you
um counselor scoby do you have any um
questions no okay thank you
um
now move on to the summary um
miss phillips ms phillips can i ask you
a question please
can you can you um tell me what the time
the time scale is for some for summing
up representations
the time scale is five minutes each
okay thank you very much okay i'd now
like to ask each party to sum up and
make final representations
so would the police like to sum up
thank you summary
from us is um conditions need to be put
on the
premise license as tomorrow the premises
could be sold to another
without any conditions the promotion of
the licensing objectives
must be priority over the trust in an
individual with regards to prevention of
crime and disorder and public safety
in mr pantene's submission he cites that
50
of his customers arrive after over 100
hours
he cites that financially 80 of his
income
is made on a friday night and 60 66
on a saturday night the sia
recommendation for three times sia
still needs to be imposed as a condition
um and that's all from me i think can i
just uh ask if there's anything else for
my colleagues
no that's all from the police thank you
okay thank you
um would the environmental health
officer like to sum up thank you
and just to say that there is of course
a potential for public nuisance from any
licensed premises
opening to the public until 4 30 a.m
three nights a week
potentially three nights a week and and
while there are
other licensed premises in the vicinity
and the area does have a vibrant
nighttime economy
we must safeguard neighbouring dwellings
and businesses from a disproportionate
and unreasonable disturbance
if members are minded to approve this
application i request
the agreed conditions um with
environmental health and the applicant
are attached to the license
okay thank you thank you very much and
um would
the um applicant um or agent
like to sum up please um
yes gladly in no particular um
order i think the first point i need to
make very clear is that
we refute this suggestion that there is
uh official guidance from the sia one to
75
ratio i've done hundreds of license
applications myself and i'm sure the
police have as well
one to one hundred is perfectly
acceptable ratio
and nick has proven over the last 15
years that a risk-assessed basis
is perfectly acceptable as well so
i please must ask you not to deliberate
on the basis that one to 75 has any
official government because as far as
i'm concerned that has not been proven
today
and i'd be the first to hold my hands up
if somebody showed me where it was
um but but that's that's a very
important point to bear in mind
i would point to the the evidence of the
last 15 years as to who is best
place to decide um how many door staff
they need
be it at three o'clock or at four
o'clock
um i regarding
uh the noise issues that have been
raised by
uh amanda i i again i i should point out
that
um nobody has objected on on the noise
basis apart from the police the police's
original concerns
did have some uh um concerns about
noise so there's no residence no hotel
owner
has objected to this application at all
and you one has to be careful
respectfully um of speculating about
these things
uh the conditions that are going on to
the license or in agreement with
environmental health
and and really uh you know are any of us
able to to look beyond that unless we
are speculating which is not
the purpose of this uh this this hearing
i i'm also concerned if i'm absolutely
honest with
it's important to investigate all the
aspects of an application
but we were pretty much one condition
regarding doorstop away
from reaching a complete agree you know
possibly a complete agreement
here and and i want to bring us back to
what unites us as it were as opposed to
what divides us and what unites us
is that nick pantellian rocket is a
really good establishment
and what we want to impress upon you in
these
kobid you know these covered times as
we're just beginning
i hope to come out of kobe is that
people like nick responsible operators
like nick need a bit of a break and i'm
not gonna be able to prove to you
conclusively that legally and
evidentially
you should grant him a four o'clock and
you should grant him a four o'clock
without imposing a door staff condition
from 1pm
but if you can't grant that to nick
pantelli at rocker
then who can you grant it to you've got
the authorities have got powers of
review they wouldn't need them with nick
anyway if there were some issues if
something went wrong
then the same conversations that have
gone on over the years with nick
would happen again and he'd he'd fix
them but there are those official
um mechanisms for enforcement so this
is this is a you know we are
imploring you please to this is where i
come back to that point of trust i made
at the start
yes there's always going to be concerns
the police environment i hope that
always going to look at it from
the lens of what happens if it goes
wrong
but you know what happens if it goes
right that's that's that's where we're
coming at it from
we will staff up on door spa when
it is needed that's what we've done
before and that's what we'll do again
and when you're talking about imposing
appropriate conditions
which is what you're required to do
under the guidance then
we would say the conditions in our
application
as drafted are the appropriate
conditions to
grant and and thank you very much for
listening uh you know so carefully to
all the arguments
um and i don't think nick's allowed to
say anything but
hopefully i've said everything he wanted
me to say
okay thank you very much
um so the members of the subcommittee
will now leave the meeting
along with the council's legal
representative to deliberate this matter
in private
we shall resume here to deliver a
verdict in 30 minutes time
whilst we leave the meeting i will ask
the democratic services officer to
explain the retiring process
absolutely so we meet back here in 30
minutes time
so chewy
[Music]
just gone 10 past so should we say 22
20 20 to 12 we'll meet back here use the
same link as we've used
to get into this me
got that full
we're just going to be five more minutes
in the uh in the little private session
we've got
there's an update for you guys
i think we're nearly there people um
it's just another couple of minutes for
us
and then we'll be back into this room
[Applause]
okay hi james can you let let me know in
everyone's present
yeah is that is everyone here that's
excellent hello mr
okay yeah people are coming back to life
that's it
so everyone i think so yes
um there's councillor here that's not in
one second
just finding the link i expect
so
have you found her james not yet
is she still in the other meeting room i
don't know i go back in
um
she's here now hey counselor
is that all of us yes
yeah i think that's all of us i'm just
gonna remove um
mr grimsey you're in twice so i'm gonna
take out one of your
accesses
okay i think we should all be good now
okay that's great um
i'd like i'd now like to invite um mrs
phillips
um litigation sister to read a summary
of the subcommittee's determination
thank you and before i read the decision
and the city just wanted everyone to
know that
it is the first time that we've
considered
an application of this nature in the
particular area
and due consideration was given to the
um to the times that we're living in in
terms of the pandemic
etc and the desire to encourage
businesses
and to move forward especially as we go
so make sure
the applicant's list is available i i
use it for the rest of the meeting and
i'll remove one of them
that's fine and so having said that
it is the application in the in the
application of rocket limited
of 64 parade ramsgate kent ct 11
8 l m for a premises license in respect
of the same
address it is the decision of the
license
district council to grant the new
presidency's license
in the application made and by rocker
limited
but subject to the condition for the
extra operating hour granted
um rocker use an extra security staff
to the front of the premises this will
be subject
to a review after 12 months from the
date
of the grant of this license
okay thanks everybody
that concludes the business for this
meeting of the licensing subcommittee